[Musica]
oggi voglio raccontarvi due storie in
realtà è la stessa identica storia vista
da due prospettive molto differenti
la prima è la narrazione della mia vita
da 37 anni a questa parte la seconda
versione ovviamente è la versione
controverso parto dalla prima storia
sono nato a corpolò un bellissimo borgo
nell'entroterra riminese fino a otto
anni ho vissuto nel paradiso terrestre
nato dall'amore dei miei genitori con
una bellissima sorella due anni in più
piccola di me un posto meraviglioso dove
giocavo tutti i giorni a calcio con i
miei amici nella piazza per otto anni ho
vissuto nel paradiso terrestre poi otto
anni all'improvviso è arrivato l'inferno
in un giorno qualsiasi di una settimana
qualsiasi di un mese qualsiasi i miei
genitori ci hanno chiesto di sedersi a
tavola dovevano dirci qualcosa di
importante la cosa importante che
dovevano dirci e che si stavano
separando il loro amore era finito non
sarebbe cambiato il loro amore nei
nostri confronti sarebbe rimasto
identico ma i loro era finito in cambio
ricevetti una scatola di meccano di
meccano erano dei giochi di legno che
andavano molto di moda negli anni 90
avevo perso la famiglia e in cambio
avevo i meccano non uno scambio
esattamente equo tra il paradiso e
l'inferno
ci sono solo un tavolo e quattro sedi a
mio padre mi abbandono si abbandonò fu
costretto ad andare a vivere in una casa
in campagna una bettola
ricordo ancora che odiamo andare a
dormire a casa di mio padre ricordo
ancora le notti fredde gelate in quella
casa e ricordo ancora il rumore dei topi
nel sottotetto mia madre rimase sola con
due bambini piccoli ci portò via dal
natio borgo selvaggio da corpolò
andammo a vivere in una casa bellissima
una villa meravigliosa a rimini
peccato che in quella villa meravigliosa
non c'erano una piazza e dei bambini con
cui giocare
mia madre poi scelse di innamorarsi
dell'orco cattivo delle favole si
innamorò di una persona che era nel
posto sbagliato
e io dovevo vivere nel posto sbagliato
senza mio padre con l'orco cattivo delle
favole
mia madre ebbe due figli con l'orco
cattivo delle favole alle medie
ero lo straniero era il ragazzo di
campagna che era arrivato in città
ero totalmente solo per fortuna
trovai un amico un amico del cuore e con
lui passai tutto il periodo delle medie
e tutto il periodo delle superiori
sfortunatamente anche lui mi tradì mi
tradì perché si innamorò della mia prima
ragazza con quella conquistavo e me la
porto via così arriviamo all'università
dove fu il periodo di maggiore
solitudine della mia vita in una casa
straniera con persone che non conoscevo
a quel punto arrivò la malattia le
malattie la prima che aggiunse verso i
26 anni sulla depressione
la depressione con seport dietro
attacchi di panico attacchi di panico
così potenti che per mesi della mia vita
non sono riuscito a uscire di casa non
riuscivo a uscire dal portone di casa
pian piano con le cure riuscire a uscire
di casa ma gli attacchi di panico sono
state una costante della mia vita negli
ultimi dieci anni
ma il grande male doveva ancora arrivare
all'età di 28 anni mi fu diagnosticato
un tumore linfoma di hodgkin un tumore
al mediastino la parte spugnosa
all'interno dei polmoni il terreno mi
crollò da sotto i piedi però affrontare
i quattro mesi di chemioterapia dentro e
fuori dall'ospedale con coraggio e dopo
la radioterapia guarin da quel momento
decisi di indossare la maschera di
batman perché ero sopravvissuto a
qualcosa che nessuno poteva sopravvivere
tutto il dolore che avevo provato era
una prova che io potessi essere speciale
e tutto quel dolore l'avrei trasformato
per proteggere le persone dal dolore e
per salvarle da quel dolore così da
batman o aperto quattro aziende
ho fatto palchi molto importanti ho
scritto due romanzi ho toccato molte
persone peccato che se avessi continuato
a tenere la maschera la mia vita
sarebbe stata una condanna la condanna
essere per sempre batman il cavaliere
oscuro il supereroe delle tenebre
ora posso raccontarvi la storia
controverso e finalmente posso liberarmi
di questa maschera essere semplicemente
andrea come mi vedete
la seconda versione della storia è molto
meno romantica ma è la verità
e adesso mi vien da ridere sono contento
in questo momento ragazzo veramente
felice parto questa è la mia nuova
immagine
questa è la verità io sono lo scarabeo
che per 37 anni della mia vita ha
continuato a spingere la sua pallina di
heathrow voi bravi ok non l'ho detto io
ha continuato a spingerla per tutta la
vita
quindi vi racconto la mia storia in
funzione di questa consapevolezza non
sono bartman sono lo scarabeo
stercorario ok non sono più batman ok
allora sono nata corpolò uno sputo di
paese che si sa se andate a dieci minuti
da qua non c'è niente niente non c'è
niente se volete andare c'è solo la
piazza fine non andate per causa di
forza maggiore i miei genitori si sono
separati finito l'amore come succede a
tutti i 50 per cento delle persone
divorziano fine
mio padre non mi ha mai abbandonato
c'è sempre stato ed era vera quella cosa
che mi amava e nei momenti di difficoltà
è sempre stato presente
mia madre è rimasta da sola con due
figli piccoli e ha sposato e si è
innamorata di un uomo giusto perché
poteva dare la sicurezza a noi bambini
di crescere in tranquillità insicurezza
economica e lei si è innamorata e da
quell'amore sono nati i miei due
fratelli michela matteo di cui sono
profondamente innamorato
il mio amico delle superiori non mi ha
abbandonato
semplicemente si è preso una sbandata a
17 anni per una ragazzina la sua prima
ragazzina come resta la mia ora arriva
la parte più complessa guardare quella
pallina e dire
ok pallina ci sei ma io ti mette un
attimo da parte gli attacchi di panico
non mi sono venuti perché avessi provato
più dolore in qualche modo io non ho
provato mai più dolore di nessuno di voi
non esiste una unità di misura del
dolore ognuno al suo
la verità è che gli attacchi di panico
mi sono venuti perché io volevo fare
pagare al mondo il prezzo di quello che
mi aveva fatto pagare
volevo dare indietro ai miei genitori al
mondo volevo fargli pagare il prezzo del
biglietto
il prezzo della mia sofferenza
uguale per il tumore il tumore era il
gesto estremo
guardate cosa avete fatto guardate
potete vederlo
io sto morendo potete vederlo
non so perché sia venuto il tumore la
realtà dei fatti scientificamente non ne
ho la più pallida idea era un bel prezzo
giusto da far pagare alle persone
guardare la mia vita oggi con questa
consapevolezza e con questa prospettiva
mi fa dire che amo profondamente la mia
famiglia la mia storia
tutte le persone esattamente come sono e
non lo cambierei con un l'altro al mondo
potevo scegliere di continuare a essere
batman per sempre ma mi sarei condannato
alla sofferenza e terna invece ho scelto
la libertà per cui adesso concludo il
mio talk con una domanda che vi voglio
fare a voi
pallina rossa scegliete di essere il
supereroe della sofferenza pallina blu
scegliete la libertà cosa scegliete
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no